I'm asked quite a bit these days.
What should I follow up?
Meaning the person asking the question,
slow carb diet or Ketogenic Diet.
And I've talked a lot about ketosis and the Ketogenic Diet in tools of titans on
the podcast when people like dom D'Agostino,
Dominic D'Agostino among others and various scientists and mds.
Here's the answer.
I think that for 90 plus percent of the people out there,
the slow carb diet is the way to go.
Slow carb diet is still what I primarily follow.
When should you use the Ketogenic Diet?
I found the ketogenic diet most helpful when a,
I was suffering from severe symptoms of Lyme disease,
which was diagnosed on long island where I had removed six embedded tech.
So it was not psychosomatic.
It wasn't misdiagnosed and that was the only thing after around,
of course,
proper antibiotic treatment in this case,
I think it was Doxycyclin
that help to,
uh,
mitigate and remove largely the cognitive decline or effectively dementia that I
felt as well as joint pain.
Ketones and the ketones and Ketogenic Diet in general have very strong
antiinflammatory effect.
And for even some conditions like say Alzheimer's.
There are people who believe if you look at Alzheimer's as say type three
diabetes or brain diabetes is some people do that.
When you offer ketones as an alternate fuel source to a brain that can no longer
metabolize or utilize glucose properly,
you can address many of the symptoms,
so ketogenic diet for me is when I have a medical condition or a problem I
cannot seem to fix via other means.
I will very frequently get into a state of Ketosis,
not through diet per se in terms of ingesting different foods,
but actually fasting and I talk about fascinating at length and different ways
to approach it in tools of titans.
I'm not going to be Labor that here.
The problem with the ketogenic diet is that if you don't get it perfectly right,
it is the worst possible diet you could follow.
What do I mean by that?
The goal of a ketogenetic diet is to get into a state of ketosis.
This means that your carbohydrate and protein consumption is low enough,
effectively zero in the case of carbohydrates and your fat intake is high
enough.
So we're talking about 75 plus percent of your calories from fat that your body
switches into.
Effectively a starvation mode where it says we're not getting the carbohydrates
and nutrients we need to produce glucose for the body,
for the brain and everything else.
So we're going to start converting fat.
That includes stored fat.
That's why you store fat,
uh,
into these alternate fuel source called ketones.
Okay?
This is a very,
very binary thing.
So you are either in Ketosis are you are not and we can measure it with safe.
A fingerprint device called the precision Xtra,
x t r a by Abbott labs.
And if you are not say at 0.5 millimolar.
So that's how the concentration is measured.
That's the number readout.
If you're not at 0.5 or higher and if you're in Ketosis,
generally people would consider the feeling that euphoria and the clarity that
you feel at say one millimolar or higher.
For some people it's even 1.5 or two.
You are in Ketosis,
but a low a lot of people,
and when I say a lot,
I would say,
uh,
more than 60% of the people who attempt to do this will fail because they will
miss things like some type of sugar that's in the mustard they use.
Or they will have some type of,
uh,
even say non-nutritive artificial sweetener that for whatever reason provokes an
insulin response or a glucose response.
Uh,
or this is a trickier one.
They aren't consuming a bunch of carbohydrates.
They followed that,
but they're eating too much protein.
And then the liver turns the extra amino acids,
uh,
via something called Gluconeogenesis into fuck,
oop,
pardon my French,
a glucose and then you're screwed again.
So there are many ways to mess up the cater to Hank Diet.
And if you think you're in Ketosis,
so you're eating 70,
80% of your calories from fat,
but you're actually using glucose,
that is arguably the worst possible diet.
You could follow your blood lipid profiles.
All of these blood markers are going to go way out of whack.
So you either get it really,
really right or it's a terrible diet.
So for people who are very,
very meticulous,
very perhaps OCD like I am and detail oriented and can really suffer through the
monotony of that diet,
it's great.
And in extreme cases also there are many people who think that it can benefit
certain cancer treatments,
uh,
whether it's chemo or radiation,
etc.
As an adjunct to supplement with say,
fasting and or the Ketogenic Diet.
Uh,
typically I recommend slow carb diet because slow carb,
I would say there is an 80% based on tracking.
Say now at this point,
closely tracking more than 2,500 people and certainly observing tens of
thousands of people following this diet,
it probably has an 80% compliance rate,
meaning over the first,
the,
the percentage of people who can stick with it for a month is certainly in the
70 to 80% range ketosis and the ketogenic diet,
I would say the percentage of people who can stick with a real strict buy
necessities,
it's binary.
Ketogenic diet is going to be less than 10%.
Okay.
So less than 10% pass rate on doing the ketogenic diet for a month.
I think that is very fair.
It is really,
really boring diet to do properly.
Unfortunately.
Uh,
now I get the benefits of Ketosis in a number of other ways.
Sometimes on days like today where I've consumed a very,
very low carbohydrate small meal,
I'll have something like this.
This is coffee with some exotic in his ketones in it,
exogenous meaning outside of the body,
so you can think exoskeleton Ekso outside exogenous or endogenous produced in
the body.
Exogenous ketones is a liquid that I pour in here.
It's called Keto force.
There are different types and it is Beta hydroxy butyrate.
It's the same thing that you measuring your blood with a finger prick when you
are say testing to see if you're in ketosis or not.
And that allows me to jack up my ketone levels.
This I think can be misused also more frequently,
at least once a month.
I'm doing say a three day fast and you want to do this with medical supervision
folks.
Don't be an amateur doctor.
I'm not a doctor.
Don't play one on the Internet,
but say from Thursday dinner to Sunday dinner,
that's enough time to get into ketosis briefly.
And I think there are other benefits to fasting that might be related,
such as triggering autophagy and deactivating or at least not activating
something called m Tor,
which talked,
uh,
with at length on the podcast with a guy,
a guy,
a very world class scientist who was shortlisted for the Nobel Prize,
uh,
named David Sabatini,
but you guys can listen to.
So,
uh,
I think there are benefits that can be derived incredible benefits from
intermittent ketosis.
That doesn't necessarily mean that you need to use a ketogenic diet.
Fasting exogenous ketones,
maybe a combination of intermittent fasting plus exogenous ketones,
et Cetera,
uh,
is very valuable as different tools in the arsenal.
But for the short answer,
and I said this top of this long winded explanation as well,
is that if I take a hundred people and I just selected at random from the
population,
I tell them to do a slow carb diet,
I would bet on at least 70% succeeding for a period of two to four weeks.
And in that period of time,
people who have a fair amount of fat to lose,
for instance,
very common.
If it's,
say someone who weighs more than let's call,
call it 200 pounds and more than 15% body fat,
that they can lose up to 20 pounds of fat.
This is very,
very common.
It's not always the case,
but very common.
Then you take another hundred people,
you put them on the ketogenetic diet and it's strict,
and then they have to self enforce.
You're not making food for them.
They have to figure it out.
I would say you're going to be looking at maximum 20% who are going to make it a
month,
and in my experience,
I've actually lost more body fat on the slow carb Diet than I have in Ketosis.
Oddly enough,
because you would think that you'd be pulling from all of your body fat stores.
Fantastic.
Well,
I've done a nine day fast,
deep,
Deep Ketosis,
right,
which is already going to be highly muscle sparing,
surprisingly and lost very little fat.
Why would that be?
Well because each pound of fat is something along the lines of 9,000 calories.
So even if you're very,
very lean,
your 5% body fat,
you have plenty of fat,
keep you alive for a week to three weeks and uh,
it's a slow burn for whatever reason.
And it could be microbiome related,
I suspect it is that when you're eating prebiotic foods on the slow carb diet
like lentils,
legumes,
et Cetera,
and also getting the thermogenic effect of food for more protein intake.
Uh,
and it's a diet that's highly compatible with say,
power training and resistance training,
different types.
For whatever reason,
I just see more fat loss on slow carbs.
So that is not why I use the ketogenic diet is mainly as a means of improving
cognitive performance and as a medical intervention.
So there you have it folks,
slow carb diet versus Ketogenic Diet.
Hope that clarifies things when in doubt,
slow carb.
That's it.
If you enjoy this video,
I want to propose you check out the podcast,
the Tim Ferriss show.
Why has it been number one on iTunes across all categories?
In some cases.
Number one in business.
Why does it have 70 million plus downloads?
Because I interviewed world class performers from athletics business.
That includes billionaires from everything imaginable.
Entertainment to tease out the routines,
the habits,
the tools that you can use.
So check it out.
The Tim Ferriss show.